do you have an intuition about why is
the fda trying to get 75 years
to release the pfizer data they're
trying to request that it will not be
released for 75 years
and then
maybe the broader version of that
question is do you think
people should have
sort of um full transparency and
immediate access to the data immediate
you know on the scale of weeks not years
i think the relations with
with regulators they have been always
very transparent and there are a lot of
laws that
they are forcing
regulators to
end companies to put out there their
interactions and what exactly was
discussed
now to to go into specific details of
of some discussions i don't know what is
the reason that fda wants to take the
time and but i'm sure they have very
good reasons
well let me just say my side of it
it doesn't look like a good reason it
looks like maybe it's because i come
from the soviet union now this is not
you saying this this is me saying this
is there seems to be a bureaucracy that
gets in the way of transparency that's
always the challenge with government so
government is very good at setting rules
and making sure there's oversight over
companies and people and so on but they
create they slow things down which is a
feature and a bug
and in this case they slowed down so
much i think the reason they said it at
75 years is because they set a rate of
being able to only review 500 pages of
data a day or something like that and
it's a very kind of bureaucratic thing
where in reality you could just show the
data
and it's not like something is being
hidden
but in the battle to win people's trust
to inspire them with science it feels
like transparency is one of the most
beautiful things one of the most
powerful things that the fda has
fda is
has the potential to be one of the great
institutions of our country and uh this
is one example that it feels
to me like a failure so in your
perspective you're saying i'm sure they
have a good reason so to you the fda is
this black box
that you submit things to once they
approve
you know that those are the rules it's
approved that's it but this is not a
black box
we know very well what
is the process everybody knows very well
what are the processes
the
review process also it is
very detailed they have scientists of
very very high caliber not every
regulator in the world but the europeans
the
the bridge the fda clearly
they have very very high caliber of
science that they are going into
a lot of details and
also
basically everything for a study is
really
released by law in the
specifications of the product but it's a
very detailed document yeah that it is
issue and has basically the essence of
everything was discussed i don't know
about uh specific documents if take them
time to release but clearly this is not
a black box type of process a lot of
this stuff is how do you effectively
communicate to the world
about the incredible science that's been
done about the processes that were
followed and i agree with you and
sometimes it's just ineloquence in
communication
it's not that there's a failure process
it's ineliquous communication and
silence
silence in the moment when clearly a lot
of people are bothered
and have questions
this is when you speak out and you
explain
exactly why
as as opposed to letting the sort of
distrust build up
and linger because the result is there's
a very large percentage of the
population that just
um
i mean it divides people
and science suffers i think
and also the effectiveness of solutions
suffers like the vaccine and so on
you